Theresa May and a blackened yellow
outfit they're walking with her husband
Philip beside her up to Downing Street
no doubt absorbing the atmosphere and
considering the words that she's now
about to say
I have just been to Buckingham Palace
where Her Majesty the Queen has asked me
to form a new government and I accepted
in David Cameron I follow in the
footsteps of a great modern Prime
Minister under David's leadership the
government stabilized the economy
reduced the budget deficit and helped
more people into work than ever before
but David's true legacy is not about the
economy but about social justice from
the introduction of same-sex marriage to
taking people on low wages out of income
tax altogether David Cameron has led a
one nation government and it is in that
spirit that I also plan to lead because
not everybody knows this but the full
title of my party is the conservative
and unionist party and that word
unionist is very important to me
it means we believe in the Union the
precious precious bond between England
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland but
it means something else that is just as
important
it means we believe in a union not just
between the nations of the United
Kingdom but between all of our citizens
every one of us whoever we are and
wherever we're from that means fighting
against the burning injustice but if
you're born poor you will die on average
nine years earlier than others if you're
black you're treated more harshly by the
criminal justice system than if you're
white if you're a white working-class
boy you're less likely than anybody else
in Britain to go to university if you're
at a state school you're less likely to
reach the top professions than if you're
educated privately if you're a woman you
will earn less than a man if you suffer
from mental health problems there's not
enough help to hand if you're young
you'll find it harder than ever before
to own your own home but the mission to
make Britain a country that works for
everyone
means more than fighting these in
Justices if you're from an ordinary
working-class family life is much harder
than many people in Westminster realise
you have a job but you don't always have
job security you have your own home that
you worry about paying the mortgage you
can just about manage but you worry
about the cost of living and getting
your kids into a good school if you're
one of those families if you're just
managing I want to address you directly
I know you're working around the clock I
know you're doing your best and I know
that sometimes life can be a struggle
the government I lead will be driven not
by the interests of the privileged few
but by yours we will do everything we
can to give you more control over your
lives when we take the big calls we'll
think not of the powerful but you when
we pass new laws
we'll listen not to the mighty but to
you when it comes to taxes we'll
prioritize not the wealthy but you when
it comes to opportunity we won't
entrench the advantages of the fortunate
few we will do everything we can to help
anybody whatever your background to go
as far as your talents will take you we
are living through an important moment
in our country's history following the
referendum we face a time of great
national change and I know because we're
Great Britain that we will rise to the
challenge as we leave the European Union
we will forge a forge a bold new
positive role for ourselves in the world
and we will make Britain a country that
works not for a privileged view but for
every one of us that will be the mission
of the government I lead and together we
will build
a better Britain